[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Good
afternoon, everybody,
and welcome to this session.
Today we're going to be talking
about machine learning options
for mobile developers.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
I'm an AI advocate at Google.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And I'm
Ibrahim from the Firebase data
local relations team.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So we
get a lot of feedback
from developers, and
particularly mobile developers,
about there are just
so many options when
it comes to machine learning.
Even at Google, we've
got all of these options.
You've probably seen
lots of this today.
You walk around
the expo hall, you
see Cloud has a
number of offerings.
We've got Firebase ML Kit.
We've got TensorFlow.
Android has some offerings.
And we get a lot of feedback
about how confusing that is.
And somebody who's a mobile
developer, who just really
wants to take advantage
of machine learning,
build that into their
mobile applications,
they need a roadmap.
They need to figure
out, what do they do?
Which offering do they use?
Which product do they use?
So what we're here today
to talk about is hopefully
to try and clear
that up a little bit,
hopefully help you understand
what the choices are when you
would make particular choices.
So the question, of course,
is, OK, where do I start?
What can machine lang--
what can machine learning--
I sometimes say
machine language,
but that's a different thing.
What can machine
learning do for me?
And really why should I care?
So I always like to
level set before I
go into some of the
offerings of machine learning
and just talk a little bit
about what machine learning is
anyway, and how we think
about it at Google,
and why we're so
excited about it.
So to me, first of all, when you
think about machine learning,
we're in the middle of this
massive hype cycle around it.
You probably see graphics like
these and blog posts and news
articles all the time, and
they're just generally talking
about machine
learning will do this,
and machine learning
will do that,
will change the world,
and machine learning
will take away our jobs.
And there's generally a
lot of hype around this
and there's a lot of
just hyperbole going on
around machine learning.
So what I wanted to do is
level set a little bit and say,
well, here's why
this is going on.
So first of all, this chart
is the typical hype cycle
around a new technology.
Now, typically, it starts
with a technology trigger.
And that technology trigger
then will lead to something
that we called the peak
of inflated expectations.
And it's because of that
peak of inflated expectations
that we're getting all
those kind of news stories
that I mentioned on
the previous slide.
After we pass through
the peak of expectations,
we tend to fall into
something called
the trough of disillusionment,
after which enlightenment will
come and then productivity.
So as an example of this,
remember back in 2007 when
Steve Jobs came
onstage and he said,
one more thing, and he
introduced the iPhone?
What happened after that was the
peak of inflated expectations.
The iPhone, the
cell phone was going
to do away with everything.
We wouldn't need desktop
computers anymore.
We wouldn't need laptop
All we would need is one of
these devices in our pocket
and it would do everything.
And while those devices
were revolutionary
and we all have smartphones
or most of us have smartphones
now, they didn't
replace the desktop.
They didn't replace the laptop.
We went through that peak
of inflated expectations.
And then, once the
trough of disillusionment
hits, when people
realized, OK, this
is what I can do with a
smartphone-- a smartphone has
a small screen, the
smartphone is touch first,
it has limited battery life.
There were various
things that I have
to still be able
to do on a desktop
that I can't do on a smartphone.
Then productivity set in
and new businessses came out
of that, things like Uber.
Can you imagine trying to
call an Uber on your laptop?
It just wouldn't work.
So when that trough of
disillusionment was hit
and people then began to
be enlightened about what
it is that you can
do with a smartphone,
then productivity hit in.
So when it comes to machine
learning, when it comes to AI,
I think we're right
about here right now.
We're still heading towards the
peak of inflated expectations.
And I like to joke that
my job as an AI advocate
is to tunnel you
through that peak
and get you straight
to disillusionment.
So I'm here today as a
professional disillusioner.
So please forgive me if
I'm a downer with that.
So let me talk about
one particular example.
Think about something
like activity detection.
Now, I'm curious, sometimes at
Next, we have a lot of coders,
sometimes we have a lot of
people who aren't coders.
Out of curiosity,
how many of you
are actual coders here,
just by show of hands?
Oh, wow, almost all of you.
OK, cool.
So think about something
like activity detection
if you're writing code.
Like, say, take,
for example, I have
a sensor that's giving me the
speed at which I'm moving.
So I can say, you know what?
If my speed is less
than four miles an hour,
I can set my status as
walking in code like this.
But now I want to
add running to that.
So now it's like, OK, if
my speed is less than four,
then I'm walking;
otherwise I'm running.
And now let's say I want
to add biking to that.
So if my speed is less
than four, I'm walking,
if it's less than 12, I'm
running; otherwise, I'm biking.
It's a basic algorithm
and it kind of works.
But then my boss,
who loves golf,
wants me to add golf to it.
All I can say is, oh, crap.
How do I write an
algorithm for that?
When I hit a golf ball it,
goes about three yards,
so I walk this far.
But when Ibrahim
hits a golf ball,
he will hit it,
what, 200 yards, 250?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Larry!
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
it's like the algorithm
for him would be a
lot different from me,
and we end up not being able
to write a reliable activity
detection.
And I know this is a very
naive algorithm based on speed,
but hopefully it gets
the point across.
So how do we solve
something like this?
Well, that's the idea
behind machine learning
and how we like to think of
machine learning at Google.
So first of all, if we talk
about traditional programming,
traditional programming is you
express rules in a programming
language, maybe Java maybe C++,
maybe JavaScript, whatever.
Those roles will act on
data, and then out of that,
you'll get answers.
Like I had earlier on, if
speed is less than four,
then I'm walking, that's
traditional programming
and as high level as I
can actually draw it.
So machine learning,
the idea behind that,
is we flip the
axes on this chart
and we end up saying,
well, what if we
have a whole bunch
of answers, and then
we have data associated
with those answers,
and then we have a
machine actually learn
the rules itself
as opposed to me
as a programmer trying
to express those rules.
Then some of the limited
scenarios and some
of the difficulties
in a scenario,
like activity detection
that I mentioned,
they could be fixed
by saying, I can
get a whole bunch
of people walking,
and I can say this is
what walking looks like.
I can get a bunch
of people running,
and say this is what
running looks like,
this is what biking looks
like, and, yeah, sort of this
is what golfing looks like.
So the idea behind
machine learning
is if I get all
of that data, then
it's just really
as simple as I can
have a computer start
sifting through this data
and spot the patterns that
make a commonality for walking,
spot the patterns that make
a commonality for running,
biking, golfing, all
that kind of stuff.
So the framework that
we've built around this
is called TensorFlow.
And TensorFlow is
what I work on.
Whoops.
Slightly broken animation there.
You didn't see that.
So going back to this diagram
that I showed you earlier on,
machine learning,
we think about it
as we're feeding in the answers,
we're feeding in the data.
We write some code in a
framework like TensorFlow
that matches the
answers to the data
and then infers the
rules out of that.
What that will do is build
what we call a model.
And a model is effectively
a neural network.
It's a really badly named
technology, between you and me,
because it's got nothing
to do with the brain,
and sometimes it makes you think
it's a lot smarter than it is.
But if you think of
a neural network,
it's basically a bunch of
interconnected functions,
and each of these
interconnected functions
calculate a probability
based on their inputs.
But what that will end
up giving us is a model.
And then at runtime, we're going
to pass data into the model,
and it will give us an inference
or a prediction out of that.
So now, again, when I was
thinking of my activity
detection, I've
trained it on a lot
of people saying what it
looks like to walk, run, bike,
and golf.
Now I'm going to pass it a
bunch of data, and it will say,
I think this looks like walking.
Instead of me writing
code, this inference
is happening based on that
data pattern matching.
So building these models is
what we call the training phase.
So as we're creating a model,
as we're passing it the data,
as we're making a neural
network to sift through
that data to come up
with the patterns that
determine one thing over
another, we call that training.
And then at runtime,
we call that inference.
So the idea now
is like, OK, now I
kind of what machine
learning's all about.
What do I do?
Where should I run my inference?
And Ibrahim is going to
tell us all about that.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So now
you have the question,
where should I do my inference?
We have two options here.
We can do the inference on the
Cloud or locally on the device.
Why I might do it in the Cloud?
If you want to integrate into
an existing Cloud service,
or you may want to use
large, complex models that
wouldn't be able to
fit in a mobile device,
or you want to use
aggregate learning
from a wide variety of sources.
And using the Cloud,
you can actually
minimize the impact
on mobile battery
and support less
performance, older devices.
What about the
case for on device?
With on device, you'll be
able to keep the data local
and avoid round trip latency.
This is particularly useful
on real-time applications
where you want to
process multiple frames
in a quick succession.
And sometimes, you want
your app to work even
when it's disconnected,
and you want
to reach users without reliable
or affordable connectivity.
And this time, you will be able.
On device is a much
better inference type.
And Lawrence will go
through the options
that Google provides here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks.
So again, thinking
about your inference,
you've built a model.
You want to run inference on it.
And as Abraham said,
there's two choices.
You can either run
it in the Cloud,
or you can run it on device.
So let's first look at if
you're going to be running
your inference in the Cloud.
So you're not deploying
a model to the device.
Here's where you see all the
Cloud-based inference and stuff
that you've been seeing
at this conference today.
So Cloud-based inference from
Google, there's three pillars.
There's computer vision-based
stuff that we call sights.
There's language-based stuff
for translation and NLP.
And then there's
conversational-based stuff.
So these are models that
have been built by Google
and services that have
been provided by Google.
So if you're meeting
these three scenarios,
and you want to run
inference in the Cloud
on these three scenarios,
it's available to you.
Now, in addition to that,
the models that we've built,
of course, can be customized.
So the customization of these
models come through the product
called AutoML.
So you see, like,
AutoML Vision allows
you to retrain Google's
Computer Vision
model to recognize your needs.
For example, you're a
manufacturer who makes widgets.
And you want some kind of
computer vision solution
that recognizes widgets.
You could use AutoML to retrain
it based on your widgets.
Or in language,
for example, if you
want to do translation, so
translation from language
to language with
machine translation,
it can be pretty good.
It's getting better
all the time,
but it's trained on
a very general set.
Again, you might
be a manufacturer
of building something that has
a specific language associated
with it.
Maybe your widgets
have particular things
associated with the
widgets themselves
that don't translate properly.
You could retrain the
machine translation models
based on your specific domain.
That's what AutoML is all about.
So that's Cloud-based
inference for these three
specific scenarios.
But then we always
get the question, OK.
It's great if it's
sights, if it's language,
or if it's conversational.
But what if I'm doing
something that's unique
and something different?
For example, somebody
asked me recently
about they wanted to do
network configuration.
And they've these
massive networks.
And right now, all of the
configuration on these networks
is done manually.
Wouldn't it be great if
they could see traffic
on these networks and then use
software-defined networking
to automatically configure
their networks based
on a learned behavior?
So there's a great example
of a custom ML model.
So the question
then becomes, well,
if I have a custom
ML model and I
want to host that in
the Cloud, what do I do?
So typically, there's
three main ways
that you build models
for machine learning.
Number one is a
pretrained model.
A little bit like I just
mentioned some of the services
that we have in
the Cloud, somebody
has built a model for you.
Those services I
showed earlier on
are models that Google
has built for you.
But we're not the only
people who build models.
So the idea is that there are
a ton of pretrained models
out there that you
just might want to use.
And you might want to
deploy them to the Cloud.
So we have a service called
TensorFlow Hub, which
is on tfhub.dev, where
the idea is that that's
a repository of
pretrained models
that might break out of the
scenarios that we're hosting
and allow you to have
a model that then you
can host in the Cloud.
The second scenario
is retraining models.
Now earlier, I
mentioned the fact
that there's those three
pillars in my previous slide
that you could retrain
those for your scenario.
But what if you have
a scenario where
there's an existing model,
and you want to retrain that?
So for example, that may
be a computer vision model
that you want to
retrain, but you don't
want to host it with AutoML.
Well, that's also possible.
You'll be able to
take a model out
of something like
TensorFlow Hub.
And you'll be able
to retrain that.
to host it yourself.
And I'll talk about hosting
it yourself in a moment.
And then, of course, there's
building from scratch.
You want to start from nothing.
You don't want to use
anybody else's model.
You have a scenario that is
so particular and so unique
to you.
And that's what
TensorFlow is all about.
So TensorFlow is
your API that will
allow you to define
neural networks
and train them so that
you can build a model.
OK.
So then you've built
a model, and you
want to host it in
the cloud yourself.
But you don't want
to use Google Cloud.
Maybe you want to host
it on your own premise.
Maybe you want to host it
in another cloud provider.
So we have something
called TensorFlow extended.
Now, the idea behind
TensorFlow extended
is it's end-to-end, enterprise
type for building, managing,
and running models.
But the orange box that
I've highlighted here
is a technology called
TensorFlow Serving.
And you could just use
TensorFlow Serving from TFX.
Deploy TensorFlow
Serving to your server
or to another cloud provider
or wherever you want to put it.
And then, you can serve
models out of that.
So we want to just try
to be able to cover
every base that we
can cover if you want
to run Cloud-based inference.
So there's really three pillars.
Number one, you can use
a service from Google
and either use that
directly or retrain it.
Number two, you can
build your own model
and host it on Google.
Or number three, you
can build your own model
and host it anywhere you like.
So those are the
three main scenarios
that we're trying to hit.
So AutoML for the first,
TensorFlow Serving
on Google Cloud for
the second, TensorFlow
Serving on your own
server or in another cloud
provider it for the third.
And if you want to learn more
about TensorFlow Extended, TFX,
you can go to
github.com/tensorflow/tfx.
It is open-sourced.
And we have our
website around it,
which is tensorflow.org/tfx.
So next up is
on-device inference.
Now, the idea is that
Abraham mentioned,
your choice where you're going
to run your inference, number
one, you can run on the Cloud.
Or number two, there was a
bunch of scenarios where you
may want to run it on-device.
Maybe you don't
want to pass data up
to a cloud to have it inferred.
You want to do
everything locally.
There's a great video
out there, for example,
of farms in Tanzania and
Africa who rely on a cassava
plant for their food.
And the problem with
the cassava plant
is that when it gets diseased,
you don't recognize the disease
until it's too late.
But they actually trained
a TensorFlow-based model
that runs on-device
that can actually
spot the disease in a plant
before the human eye can
spot the disease.
And all they have to do is
hold their phone over it, point
the camera at the
leaf of this plant,
and it spots the disease
with 99% plus accuracy.
And as a result, they
can root that plant out
before it infects
the rest of the crop.
Now, this is on a
farm in Tanzania,
where they don't have
broadband connectivity.
They don't have 4G
et cetera, et cetera.
So everything has
to run on-device.
So that's just a great example
of there are scenarios where
you may want to run
on-device beyond just privacy
and all that kind of thing.
So when it comes to
models on device,
it's actually the
same three choices.
Number one, pretrained models--
in the example of the cassava--
sorry.
A pretrained model is
you can go to TF Hub.
You can download a
pretrained model.
And you can just
use that directly.
Then, there's retrained models.
And in the example of the
cassava, what they did was
they downloaded something
called MobileNet.
And MobileNet is
a well-known model
that's optimized for mobile use
and recognizes 1,000 classes.
But then, they
retrained that based
on leaves that they
were able to categorize,
this is a disease leaf.
This is an un-diseased leaf.
And again, using the same
thing that I mentioned
with the activity
detection, you can train it
that this is what a
diseased leaf looks like.
This is what an un-diseased leaf
looks like, that type of thing.
So they were able to retrain
and build a model out of that.
Or of course, you can
just build from scratch.
You can create your own
model, and off you go.
But when it comes to
on-device, there's
one extra step that
you need to do,
and that's to convert
your model to optimize
it to run on the device.
What this does is,
it shrinks the model.
It makes it not
battery safe, but it
makes it better for working with
battery, those kind of things.
So there's four steps in this.
First of all, you
build your model
by either using a
pre-trained, retraining,
or creating a
model from scratch.
And in TensorFlow,
then, you save it
as what's called a saved model.
So saved model is a file format
that we're standardizing on
in TensorFlow 2.
And the idea behind saved
model is when you use that file
format, it will work on
enterprise-grade scenarios
in the Cloud.
It will work on mobile.
It will work in
JavaScript, in the browser,
that type of thing.
To be able to get it
to work on mobile,
then, there's TF Lite Converter,
which shrinks that model,
freezes parts of
it, and allows you
to use it on TensorFlow Lite.
So you go through these
steps for model conversions
so that you can then execute
your model on a mobile device.
And when I say
mobile device, we're
actually moving beyond
just iOS and Android.
The same process will be able to
be used so that your model will
then work on embedded systems.
So we recently released
support for microcontrollers,
some microcontrollers
and embedded systems
like IoT-type devices
like Raspberry Pi.
So let me give a
quick demo of this
if we can switch to
the demo machine.
And my screen saver kicked
in while I was talking.
Thanks.
All righty.
So I'm actually going to run
this on the Android emulator.
So we can see running on
the Android emulator now.
This is a little app that's
running in TensorFlow Lite.
So it's an open source app
you can go and download this
now if you like.
And what this is doing
is, it's grabbing frames
from the webcam.
It's emulating the webcam using
the front camera on my laptop.
And then, it's classifying
those frames using MobileNet.
MobileNet, as I
mentioned earlier on,
is built to work with
1,000 different classes.
So what it's doing,
frame by frame,
is it's taking the
frame from the webcam.
It's compressing that
to the size of the image
that MobileNet wants to use.
It's passing it to
TensorFlow Lite.
It's getting back
1,000 classifications.
It's picking the top
three and then rendering
those on the screen.
So for example, if I hold up
a water bottle, we can see--
I did say water bottle.
Eh, there we go.
It's hard to get it
right with the angle.
I usually have a
banana for this.
I forgot to bring
a banana with me.
And we didn't have
a backup banana.
There we go, water bottle, 100%,
so that that kind of thing.
So if I, then,
just move this up--
sometimes I put my face in it.
And I don't know
what it wants to say.
But so we can see the
inference time here.
Now, this is running on
the Android emulator.
I'm sorry if it's really small.
With the inference time,
it's about 300 milliseconds
on an Android emulator.
If you run this on a device,
particularly an Android device
that has a neural networks API
installed, like, for example,
like a Pixel-- if you want
to see it running on my Pixel
later, I can show you--
it'll do the inference
in about 30 milliseconds.
It's super, super, super fast.
So we've been building
TensorFlow Lite with that
in mind to shrink the
model, to optimize it,
to make it super
fast for inference.
So you can even do like
near real-time inference
like this running on an emulator
on my laptop, which I think
is really cool.
So that's the demo if we can
switch back to the slides.
So in summary, for the
choices that you're facing,
we realize that this is
a very confusing thing.
So part of what I've
been trying to drive
in Google is a bit of
a strategy around, OK,
what do mobile developers
need for machine learning?
And it was driven off of
a flowchart like this one.
And I'm sorry if
it's really small.
But that's kind of
part of the intent,
that we understand that
it's very confusing.
But if we think
about this, if we
look at the left-hand
side of this flowchart,
those are the options that
are available if you want
to run inference on mobile.
And if you want to
copy this flowchart,
just drop me an email.
I'm happy to send it to
you because I know it's
pretty small to see on here.
And if you look at
the right-hand side
of this flowchart,
those are the options
that are available
to Cloud developers.
So the idea is if you want to
run inference on mobile device,
there are a number of scenarios.
Maybe you want to have
it connected to the Cloud
to do your inference.
Maybe you want it disconnect
it from the Cloud.
Those are the things on the
left side of the flowchart.
Ditto on the right side if you
want to use Google services
or if you want to host your own
models, those kind of things.
But we also have an
offering that Abraham
is going to talk about
that gives us both.
So the idea is-- and Abraham
probably will be best
to explain it with ML Kit.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks, Laurence.
As Laurence
described, ML options
may look like a
[INAUDIBLE] at first look
because you would like
to provide tailored
solutions for each use case.
As a developer, you want to
implement these solutions
together.
Hence, you can use the
ML Kit as a single SDK.
ML Kit is a mobile SDK that
brings Google's machine
learning expertise to
Android [INAUDIBLE]
in a powerful, but
easy-to-use package.
It comes with a set
of ready-to-use APIs.
We'll call them base APIs.
And they work for both on-device
and Cloud-based inferences.
They support common
mobile use cases
like image labeling, face
detection, texture cognition,
and barcode scanning,
to name a few.
While they're all ML
models under the hood,
they're as easy to
use as any other API.
Let's look at a typical
workflow of someone
looking to implement a machine
learning model in an app.
So first, the ML expert,
data scientist gathers,
massages, and splits the data;
brings or creates a model;
trains, tunes and
evaluate the model.
Maybe they will have to
do this in a few loops.
And then, the DevOps
will deploy the model.
And finally, the
software developer
will do the prediction.
But ML Kit makes
this way easier.
You simply pass in the
data to the ML Kit library,
and it will give you the
information you need.
Whether you are new to or
experienced with machine
learning, you can
implement the functionality
in a few lines of code.
And it includes both
Android and iOS libraries.
While on-device APIs process the
data quickly and will work even
when there is no
network connection,
the Cloud-based API has
leveraged the power of Google
Cloud platforms,
machine learning
technology to give powerful,
high-accuracy results.
Let's look at a
specific example.
As you can see here,
we are building
an app that requires
identifying the teams
and content of an image.
You would be using the
image labeling API.
In the cart, you'll be
seeing two icons here.
On-device APIs
are free of charge
and are best suited
for scenarios
where you need a low
latency, and you might not
have a network
connection, and you're
OK with a more
coarse-grained answer.
On the other hand, the Cloud
calls come at a free quota,
but are paid beyond that.
They provide the most accurate
results and are powered
by the state-of-the-art
machine learning models running
on the Google Cloud Platform.
But if you do have
some ML experience
or would like to bring
your own custom models,
as Laurence already described,
you can do that too.
And using ML Kit
with that, you'll
be able to run your TensorFlow
Lite models on the underlying
framework, whether
it's Android or iOS.
And you'll get further
benefits from ML Kit
since it's integrated into the
Firebase, such as analytics,
remote config, and A/B testing.
Maybe not everyone is
familiar with Firebase.
So Firebase is Google's
mobile development platform
which has tools for
building better apps,
improving app quality, and
further growing your business.
So with using ML
Kit with Firebase,
we'll actually allow you
to upload your TF Lite
models into the Firebase
console and dynamically
deploy them to your users.
This means that the APK bundle
size can be really kept small
since you won't be
actually putting
the model inside the APK.
And you can do
frequent roll-outs
without having to
republish your app.
And you can further
run A/B experiments.
Firebase features, such as
A/B testing, remote config,
analytics make this
process real easy.
And I would like to
walk through a demo
and show all these
features to you.
Thanks a lot.
So let's start
with the base APIs.
This is a small
sample, actually.
I was using only
the base APIs here.
Let's do some detection.
As I already described
on image labeling,
let's start with that.
When I start using the on-device
APIs, they are really fast,
and I get some answers here,
like beach, rock, sky, cliff.
And they're pretty good.
But if I want even finer results
and way better accuracy, then
I can use the Cloud.
Here, I am actually
detecting from the Cloud.
As you can see now, I get
more finer grade answers,
such as "body of
water," "sky," "wave,"
"shore," that weren't actually
in the on-device API call.
And we already described
some use cases there.
Maybe some use cases were
on-device APIs were better
or the Cloud APIs were better.
And in such a use
case, let's say
we are doing a face detection.
We will need to
use on-device API
because we want to actually
process those frames really
faster.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think
you look great in lipstick,
by the way.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I am not sure.
So it's face detection,
and we get the contours.
And we are using
the on-device API
here so that we can actually
process these frames
without having to
go back to network
and waiting for the
network response.
But as we said,
like ML Kit, we were
able to use even hybrid
solutions because we
are using a single SDK.
There's another
demo I did earlier.
Let's see how it works.
But this is actually, the
results coming on the top
are coming from the device
API because I want actually
get these frames as
quickly as possible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I did not
use my Mac for making music.
So saying it's a musical
instrumental is accurate.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
We'll see about that.
So I want to trigger it.
It starts with the musical
instrument, as you see there.
It was on-device API.
But, at the same time, I
did a call to the Cloud API.
And I was able to select
the label with a laptop,
with a better answer because
I was actually getting
the laptop from the Cloud API.
I can do a few other things.
For some reason, I'm
getting a lot of Clouds in.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, there we go.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: As you
see, it takes a change
from like the
musical instrument.
AUDIENCE: Is everything
a musical instrument?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Definitely.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I hope not.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Everything is
a potential musical instrument
when you think about it.
So this is.
Sitting, arm.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
[INAUDIBLE]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
And on top of that,
we also mentioned
about the custom model.
So you can actually bring
your own model to ML Kit
as well on the
framework of TF Lite.
So I was actually using a
local model local model here
and doing the image labeling
with my MobileNet or model.
And, also, I can use
the Firebase to download
another model from the remote.
And I can use this time
using the same image labeling
from my remote model.
This way, I was able to
use another model that
wasn't in the APK or
in the bundle before.
But not only that,
we can actually
further use Firebase to
go one level higher here.
This is my Firebase console.
If we are not familiar
with it, that I'll
be actually using the console
for my mobile development.
Here, in the ML Kit section,
I have some custom models.
In these models, I see
the image classification,
invalid model, some models
that I already published,
so they can be downloaded
on the fly from my client.
Let's say I want to do
some A/B experiment.
I want to see if I have
a better model, if it's
really better or worse,
or how will my users
react to this new model?
We can actually
run an A/B testing.
An A/B testing lets me
use some of these models
or some of the other parameters
on the fly to my app.
We'll use a remote config,
which my clients will
be able to get some
configs on the fly again.
Let's say the ML experiment
name is mlkit, just
for the sake of example.
And here, I will be
selecting my app.
For the sake of
example, I'm just
going to say 5% of
target users, which
I will be rolling my new model.
And I want to have
some goals so I
can track some metrics that
if my new model is successful.
Let's say daily user engagement,
one of the common goals,
the [INAUDIBLE].
So I will be creating
some parameters
so I can change these
models on the fly.
Let's say ml_model_name.
And one of my models
is image labeling.
And I can create a
new experiment now
with a different variant.
So the 5% of my
users can actually
get the version 2 model.
With that, I will be
starting an experiment.
And I'll do a click Review here.
And from now on, I can
actually start the experiment
and see how my users will react.
To the experiment,
I can see things
that like that if
there is a better user
engagement, this model.
Or maybe my users are actually
having a lower churn rate.
Or if I'm selling something
from my in-app store,
maybe they will be getting like
more stuff, because they really
found what they were looking
for using the ML model.
Can we go back to slides?
As I explained, I just
started this experiment,
so I won't have the data ready.
But there was another
one, actually.
I did the experiment before.
Here, I can see clearly
with different variants
that one of the model ended up
having a lower user engagement,
and the other model
made my users stay more.
Maybe they really found what
they were looking in my app
using this new model.
So using these
experiments, I can really
find the best model I can use
and I can even process and get
better models to go from there.
As Lawrence already
described, Google
provides so many
different options.
Either you are a new or
experienced ML developer,
or you want to do your inference
on the Cloud or on the device.
And, if you want to bring
your custom model, or you
want to use the Google model.
And with ML Kit, we can actually
use it from a single SDK.
And it's easier
sometimes if you want
to use the base APIs,
a few lines of code,
or you can bring your
own model as well.
And you can further use
Firebase to get analytics
and to actually match
your different ML models
and see how they perform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]